Arguably, one of the most
important molecules in all of
biology is ATP.
ATP, which stands for adenosine
triphosphate.
Which sounds very fancy.
But all you need to remember,
or any time you see ATP
hanging around in some type
of biochemical reaction,
something in your brain should
say, hey, we're dealing with
biological energy.
Or another way to think of ATP
is the currency-- I'll put
that in quotes-- of
biological energy.
So how is it a currency
of energy?
Well ATP stores energy
in its bonds.
And I'll explain what that
means in a second.
And before we learn what
an adenosine group or a
3-phosphate group looks like,
you can just take a bit of a
leap of faith, that you could
imagine ATP as being made up
of something called-- let me
do it in a nice color-- an
adenosine group right there.
And then attached to it you'll
have three phosphates.
Not might, you will.
You'll have three phosphates
attached to it just like that.
And this is ATP.
Adenosine triphosphate.
Tri- meaning three
phosphate groups.
Now if you take adenosine
triphosphate and you hydrolyze
this bond, which means
if you take this in
the presence of water.
So let me just throw
some water in here.
Let's say I have H2O.
Then one of these phosphate
groups will break off.
Essentially part of this water
joins to this phosphate group,
and then part of it
joins to this
phosphate group right there.
And I'll show you that in a
little bit more detail.
But I want to give you the
big picture first.
What you're left with is an
adenosine group that now has
two phosphates on it.
And this is called adenosine
diphosphate or ADP.
Before we had triphosphate,
which means three phosphates.
Now we have diphosphate,
adenosine triphosphate, so
instead of a tri here
we just write a di.
Which means you have two
phosphate groups.
And so the ATP has been
hydrolyzed, or you have broken
off one of these phosphate
groups.
And so now you're left with
ADP and then an extra
phosphate group right here.
And-- and this is the whole key
to everything that we talk
about when we're dealing
with ATP-- and
you have some energy.
And so when I talk about ATP
being the currency of
biological energy,
this is why.
Is that if you have ATP, and if
you were to-- through some
chemical reaction-- you pop off
this phosphate right here.
It's going to generate energy.
That energy can be used
for just general heat.
Or you could couple this
reaction with other reactions
that require energy.
And then those reactions will
be able to move forward.
So, I draw these circles.
Adenosine and phosphates.
And really, this is all
you need to know.
Already, what I've shown you
right here is really all you
need to know to operationally
think of how ATP operates in
most biological systems.
And if you want to
go the other way.
If you have energy and you
want to generate ATP, the
reaction will just
go this way.
Energy plus a phosphate group
plus some ADP, you
can go back to ATP.
And so this is stored energy.
So this side of the equation
is stored energy.
And this side of the equation
is used energy.
And this is really all you--
well this is 95% of what you
need to know to really
understand the function of ATP
in biological systems. It's just
a store of energy when
you-- ATP has energy.
When you break a phosphate
off, it generates energy.
And then if you want to go from
ADP and a phosphate back
to ATP, you have to use
energy up again.
So if you have ATP, that's
a source of energy.
If you have ADP and you want
ATP, you need to use energy.
And so far I've just drawn a
circle with an A around it and
said that's an adenosine.
But sometimes I think it's
satisfying to see what the
molecule actually looks like.
So I cut and pasted this
from Wikipedia.
And the reason why I didn't show
this to you initially is
because this looks
very complicated.
While the conceptual reason
why ATP is the currency of
energy, I think is fairly
straightforward.
When it has three phosphates,
one phosphate can break off.
And then that'll result
with some energy being
put into the system.
Or if you want to attach
that phosphate you
have to use up energy.
That's just the basic
principle of ATP.
But this is its actual
structure.
But even here we can break it
down and see that it's really
not too bad.
We said adenosine.
Let me draw the adenosine
group.
We have adenosine.
This right here is adenosine.
This part of the molecule
right there.
That is adenosine.
And for those of you that have
really paid attention to some
of the other videos, you might
recognize that this part of
adenosine-- so this is called
adenosine, but this part right
here-- is adenine.
Which is the same adenine that
makes up the nucleotides that
are the backbone of DNA.
So some of these molecules in
biological systems have more
than one use.
This is the same adenine
where we talk
about adenine and guanine.
This is a purine.
And there's also the
pyrimidines, but I won't go
into that much.
But that's the same molecule.
So that's just an interesting
thing.
The same thing that makes up DNA
is also part of what makes
up these energy currency
molecules.
So the adenine makes part of
the adenosine part of ATP.
And then the other part
right here is ribose.
Which you might also recognize
from RNA, ribonucleic acid.
That's because you have
ribose dealing
in the whole situation.
But I won't go into that much.
But ribose is just
a 5-carbon sugar.
When they don't draw the
molecule, it's implied that
it's a carbon.
So this is one carbon right
there, two carbons, three
carbons, four carbons,
five carbons.
And that's just nice to know.
It's nice to know that they
share parts of their
molecules with DNA.
And these are familiar building
blocks that we see
over and over again.
But I want to emphasize that
knowing this, or memorizing
this, in no way will help you
understand the simpler
understanding of ATP
just being what
drives biological reactions.
And then here I drew 3-phosphate
groups, and this
is their actual molecular
structure.
Their Lewis structures
right here.
That's one phosphate group.
This is the second
phosphate group.
And this is a third
Just like that.
When I first learned this, my
first question was, OK I can
take this as a leap of faith
that if you take one of these
phosphate groups off or if this
bond is hydrolyzed, that
somehow that releases energy.
And then I kind of went on and
answered all the questions
that I had to answer.
But why does it release
energy?
What is it about this bond
that releases energy?
Remember all bonds are are
electrons being shared with
different atoms.
So the best way you could think
about it is right here.
These electrons that are being
shared right across this bond,
or this electron that's being
and it's coming from
the phosphate.
I won't draw the periodic
table right now.
But you know the phosphate has
five electrons to share.
It's less electronegative than
oxygen, so oxygen will kind of
hog the electron.
But this electron is
very uncomfortable.
There's a couple of reasons
why it is uncomfortable.
It's in a high energy state.
One reason why is, you
have all these
negative oxygens here.
So they kind of want to push
away from each other.
So these electrons in this bond
really can't kind of get
close to the nucleus.
They'll go into kind of
a low energy state.
All of this is more of an
analogy than the reality.
We all know that electrons
can get quite complex.
And there's a whole quantum
mechanical world.
But that's a good way
to think of it.
That these molecules want to
be away from each other.
But you have these bonds, so
this electron, it's kind of in
a high energy state.
It's further from the nucleuses
of these two atoms
than it might want to be.
And when you pop this phosphate
group off, all of a
sudden these electrons
can enter into a
lower energy state.
And that generates energy.
So this energy right here is
always-- in fact in any
chemical reaction where they say
energy is generated, it's
always from electrons going
to a lower energy state.
That's what it's all about.
And later in future videos
when we do cellular
respiration and glycolysis and
all that, whenever we show
energy, it's really from
electrons going from
uncomfortable states to more
comfortable states.
And in the process they
generate energy.
If I'm in a plane or I'm jumping
out of a plane, I have
a lot of potential energy
right when I
jump out of the plane.
And you can view that as
an uncomfortable state.
And then when I'm sitting on my
couch watching football, I
have a lot less potential
energy, so that's a very
comfortable state.
And I could have generated
a lot of energy
falling to my couch.
But I don't knows.
My analogies always break
down at some point.
Now, the last thing I want to go
over for you is exactly how
this reaction happens.
So far you could turn off this
video and you could already
deal with ATP as it is used
in 95% of biology,
especially AP Bio.
But I want you to understand
how this
reaction actually happens.
So to do that, what I'm going
to do is copy and
paste parts of these.
So I already told you that this
guy right here is going
to break off of the ATP.
So that's the phosphate
group that breaks off.
And then you have
the rest of it.
You have the ADP that's
left over.
So this is the ADP.
I don't even have to copy and
paste all of this stuff.
You can just accept that that's
the adenosine group.
Just like that.
So we've already said that this
thing gets hydrolyzed
off, or gets cut off and
that generates energy.
But what I want to
do is actually
show you the mechanism.
A little bit of hand-wavy
mechanism of how
this actually happens.
So I said this reaction occurs
in the presence of water.
So let me draw some
water here.
So I have an oxygen
and a hydrogen.
And then I have another
hydrogen.
That's water right there.
So hydrolysis is just a reaction
where you say, hey,
this guy here, he wants to
bond with something or he
wants to share someone
else's electrons.
So maybe this hydrogen right
here goes down here and shares
its electron with this
oxygen right here.
And then this phosphorus, it has
an extra electron that it
needs to share.
Remember it has five valence
electrons; it wants to share
them with oxygen.
It has one, two, three, four
being shared right now.
Well, if this hydrogen goes to
this guy, then you're left
with this blue OH right here.
And this guy can share
one of the
phosphorus' extra electrons.
So you get the OH
just like that.
So that's the actual process
that happens.
And it could go the
other way as well.
I could've cleaved it here.
I could have cleaved the
whole thing here.
And so this guy would have
kept the oxygen and the
hydrogen would have
gone to him.
And then this guy would
have taken the OH.
It could happen in
either order.
And so either order
would be fine.
And there's one other point
I want to make.
And this is a little
bit more complex.
And I was even wondering whether
I wanted to make it.
My whole reason why you're
kind of in a lower energy
state is, once you break apart--
actually let me go
down here-- is because I said,
hey, this electron is happier
when it's-- so let's say this
electron that was part of this
phosphorus is happier now.
It's in a lower energy
state because
it's not being stretched.
It's not having to spend time
between that guy and that guy
because this molecule and this
molecule want to spread apart
because they have negative
charges.
That's part of the reason.
The other reason why, and we'll
talk about this in a lot
more detail when we learn more
about organic chemistry, is
that this has more resonance.
More resonance structures or
resonance configurations.
And all that means is that these
electrons, these extra
electrons here, they can kind
of move about between the
different atoms. And that makes
it even more stable.
So if you imagine that this
oxygen right here has an extra
electron with it.
So that extra electron right
there, it could come down here
and then form a double bond
with the phosphorus.
And then this electron right
here can then jump back up to
that oxygen.
And then that could happen on
this side and on that side.
And I won't go into the details,
but that's another
reason why it makes
it more stable.
If you've already taken organic
chemistry, you can
kind of appreciate that more.
But I don't want to get
all into the weeds.
The most important thing to
remember about ATP is that
when you cleave off a phosphate
group it generates
energy that can drive all sorts
of biological functions,
like growth and movement,
muscle movement, muscle
contraction, electrical
impulses in
nerves and the brain.
So this is the main battery
or currency of energy in
biological systems. That's the
main thing that you really
just need to remember
about ATP.